here it is nvidia's new RTX 580 compared
to its predecessor the 4080 super it is
around 15% faster in games that use its
new features it's faster in AI as long
as you don't need more than 16 gigs of
RAM for your model it's more efficient
even though it draws more power overall
and it's got a great cooler design as
long as you don't mind heating up your
CPU and that's it that's the most
positive spin we can put on this thing
why the do we need all of these caveats
when we say the new one is better than
the old one I mean isn't the point of
the new one to be clearly and
substantially better well it is better
in cranked out cyberpunk at 4K it not
only beats the 480 super but it even
gives the 490 a run for its money but
it's such a mixed bag that in other
situations it barely out competes the
7900 XTX the flagship GPU that made AMD
think you know maybe we just shouldn't
do flagships anymore hey class half full
at least they didn't raise the price and
we did find some situations where the 80
offers up pretty compelling use case and
if you don't mind the weirdness of
generated frames maybe Nvidia is onto
something with the neural rendering
stuff we're going to tell you more about
it after I nearly render a better way to
sell your used
Hardware is it available
yeah is it available yeah again is it
available
just let her sponsor Jawa buy your old
gpus no need for more stupid questions
yeah so are you
interested before we explore the
wildlands of AI assisted rendering let's
get our bearings with some good
oldfashioned 1440p results all raster no
DLS upscaling or rate tracing in
cyberpunk the 580 makes a great first
impression with a 20% lead over the 480
super then in Allen wake the 580 brings
a decent generation uplift that brings
1% low FPS into the triple digits but
also it uh only barely outpaces the 7900
XTX here in f124 things look even less
exciting with the 580 failing to
overtake amd's now 2-year-old Flagship
and only offering a measly 7ish per
uplift over the 480 super does it get
any better no no again and triple no why
does the last gen 4070 TI super make
everything else here look like an
overpriced joke at least Blackmouth
Wukong provides a reason for the 580 to
exist but overall I'm just kind of
getting sad reading you all these charts
and you can expect a roughly 10% uplift
over the 480 super and just 7% over the
7900 XTX if you're curious about the 480
nons super there's a reason we called it
the 480 cheaper it performs basically
identically and you can't buy it anymore
so we opted to use our limited graph
space for older cards that might
actually be worth upgrading from all
right well maybe the story changes at
4K oh yeah okay so it's a bit Happ
happier but this feels a little bit like
going from Bridge to Terabithia to Dead
Poet Society on average the 80 takes a
commanding 18% lead over its predecessor
which is good but that parade gets
somewhat rained on by its mere 10% lead
over the 7900 XTX there are a couple of
standouts that Merit specific mention
here black myth Wukong has the 580
taking a price appropriate lead over the
7900 XTX with a worthwhile uplift over
the 480 super and that's also true in
cyberpunk where
again the 80 nearly catches the 4090
losing only in the less important
average FPS but that one result there
it's less of a trend and more of just an
outlier in other titles it seems like
the 80 is content to just be its
disappointing self better but not better
enough of course Nvidia doesn't think
that traditional raster rendering is the
way forward no their way forward is with
the AI GPU Hardware that made them the
most valuable company in the world
and any conflicting data would almost
certainly mean a cratering stock
price so with the AI boom in mind Nvidia
focused most of their architectural
upgrades on that if you want to learn
more about the architectural and
Technology upgrades we highly recommend
you check out our 5090 review where we
spend a bit more time explaining what
everything means what really matters for
gamers is how this car differs from the
4080 and 4080 super it's not much we're
still on tsmc's 4N process node but at
the same MSRP we get get four more
streaming multiprocessors in the 480
super along with a clock speed bump and
a memory swap from 16 GB of gdr 6X to 16
GB of gdr 7 that all explains why raw
gaming performance isn't improved much
the bigger improvements come in the form
of Next Generation Nvidia Ray tracing RT
cores and AI accelerating tensor cores
the tensor cores also now have Hardware
support for fp4 calculations for
improved performance and memory usage
with lightweight AI models and are more
tightly integrated with Cuda course to
make way for the Sci-Fi sound in neural
rendering for hypothetical future Gamers
these neural rendering techniques
actually sound really cool and they
might turn out great but Gamers
shouldn't feel pressure to upgrade until
a must playay title that uses them hits
the steam store instead feel pressured
to buy our Precision multi-bit
screwdriver bundle from LTT store.com
anywh who those working with high-end
video might upgrade for the New Media
engine on the 5000 series that provides
support for 422 chroma sub sampling in a
nutshell this means much higher quality
Hardware accelerated video encoding
which will be a boon for professionals
and anyone who likes streaming games to
a hand old or lightweight decoding box
we're also stoked about display port 2.1
uhb 20 the 580 can drive 4K 240 HZ with
no display stream compression and even
go higher with DSC which doesn't impact
image quality as far as our eyes can
perceive that means no compromises
between image quality and latency and
responsiveness let's move on to Ray
tracing where yeah Nvidia is really just
competing against themselves here but is
more big titles list Ray tracing as a
minimum requirement it's becoming
something that just can can't be brushed
off which is a problem for AMD at 1440p
while AMD can survive lightly rate
traced games the path tracing found in
Allen wake and Blackmouth Wukong make
AMD look like an 8-year-old kid made it
onto the field at an NFL game hopefully
that will change with amd's 9000 series
of gpus but we don't know for sure today
across our suite of games the 80
maintains the same performance margin
over the 480 super that we saw in our
raster tests but fails to scale as well
as the 490 does into 4K maybe the 490 is
extra RT cors give it the edge or maybe
it's the vram check out this result in
Allan Wake 2 why did so many cards fail
miserably guess now did you say lack of
vram well you're right and if you didn't
say lack of vram pretend that you did 4K
path traced Allen wake asks for over 15
GB of vram on 50 Series cards and over
16 on AMD cards anything less and it's
wholly unplayable well we can't say that
it causes a performance hit on the 580
it highlights just how skimpy 16 GB of
vram feels on a $1,000
card and how close we are to a future
where it's necessary for high-end gaming
and the more frustrating thing is that
if you want more vram from Team Green
you literally have to spend twice as
much for a 5090 or go back a generation
or two I digress the rest of the 4K RT
results show that the 580 is still a
mean green ray tracing machine it's just
not that much meaner than the 4080 super
another disappointing result for the
5,000 series for productivity the story
is more mixed while it doesn't do much
to impress in our blender render in
Premiere Pro we can see that the updated
media engine on the new 50 Series puts
in the work beating the 4090 by 5% with
a similar lead in Da Vinci resolve we'd
love to talk about improvements to
encoding but we're working on our
benchmarks for that let us cook but who
needs to shoot and edit videos when you
could just generate garbage while
wasting precious Earthly resources in AI
the 5080 manages a 20% lead over the
4080 super in our Tex generation
benchmarks with the only Hiccup being a
smaller lead in our 53.5
in our stable diffusion image generation
benchmarks we see 16 is% improvement
over the 4080 super which is cool I
guess sadly a lack of vram will limit
the models you can play with wamp wamp
but this is positioned as a gaming card
so let's talk about the AI that makes
games run good D lss4 is a massive
overhaul from dss3 it switches from a
CNN model to a Transformer model if you
want to learn more about the theory you
should check out our 5090 review what it
means in practice is that dss4 allows
for better image quality at the same
settings with some caveats of course
it's the 50 Series there's going to be
caveats there's a performance hit using
the new Transformer model while the
effect is mild for things like super
resolution digital Foundry saw that
older cards can take a real hit from
enabling certain features with the new
model but it scales better which means
that the 50 Series and all of its tensor
core huta generates up to three frames
for every rendered frame essentially
quadrupling your FPS multiframe gen is
impressive and despite generating so
many frames the tech does not impact
latency substantially at least over top
of your base frame rate sadly more
frames is not more performance if you
were to run a game natively at 30 FPS
each frame would have 33 milliseconds of
latency running at 60 FPS would half
your latency to
16.66% 33 milliseconds of latency which
is 25 milliseconds worse than rendering
120 FPS natively a large disparity
meanwhile if you quadruple your 12 FPS
game to 480 FPS well that only results
in about a 6 millisecond difference in
latency Which is far less noticeable but
here's the kicker MFG has a performance
overhead that will reduce your base
frame rate and the more frames you gen
the more overhead you need to contend
with that's why we don't see a literal
quadrupling of frames this means that
using it to bump up an already low frame
rate will make it feel even worse to
play as it adds more latency there's a
ton of nuance to this deck and we would
recommend checking out Hardware unbox
excellent video on it the good news is
that multiframe gen scales about as well
in the 5080 as it did on the 5090
hopefully this trend carries forward to
the lower 50 Series because it did not
carry over to the lower end of the 40
series sheesh so tldr the higher your
base frame rate the better your frame
gen will feel but the less you need it
Nvidia likes to pretend that frame gen
is comparable to Native rendering in
their marketing but it's just not should
you forgo MFG and just stick with the
new dss4 Transformer model on the 80
you'll see about a 5% % lower frame rate
for the improved image quality and we
think it's worth the tradeoff now all of
this talk of frame rates and latency
might have you wondering how does the
580 fair in Esports well it does a dang
good job we didn't test the rest of the
lineup today because frankly any of the
high-end cards will give you a great
experience in Esports titles but this is
a reminder that despite our Dow and
disappointed tone it's still a very
high-end very performant card and that
also means it has big Power draw the
5080 gets the same sleek and Innovative
double flowr cooler as the 5090 allowing
it to stay at a reasonable 70° in
combuster despite pulling as much as 403
Watts if you're going to small form
factor you're far less likely to bump up
against the thermal limits of this car
than with the 5090 when gaming the
average atts drop further to 65° thanks
to the lower power budget in f124 we see
the 580 pulling an average of 337 Watts
nearly 15% more than the 480 super this
Nets around 14% more frames which
indicates no efficiency gains just like
we saw in the 5090 by
feeling deflated me too taking
everything into account we have a Next
Generation card that outperforms its
last gen counterpart by 10 to 20% using
roughly 15% more power I mean at least
the price is the same that's that's good
even then it feels like it could have
been a midcycle refresh or a 4080 TI
given it doesn't catch the 490 and raw
performance something we really hoped it
would do at best if you're considering
the 480 super the 80 might be enough to
push you over the edge to buy at least
at MSRP but that's the hardest working s
in the world because last gen cards are
nearly impossible to find at nvidia's
suggested price and if the 5090 is
anything to go by this generation will
be the same or even
worse it feels like Nvidia just doesn't
care much about Gamers and that's
because they don't they care about AI
That's What made them one of the most
valuable companies in the world and
they're trying to use their large market
share to move the market in their
Direction they're saying no no no no no
you don't want more raster what the
wants nay what it needs is AI and AI
just so happens to need the proprietary
features enabled by the chips that we
produce I get it if they were to admit
that AI Hardware wasn't the solution to
every conceivable problem then it would
crater their stock price a thing that
actually just happened on Monday the
moment a Chinese AI company with limited
access to nvidia's best AI Hardware
supposedly overtook chat GPT team
Green's stock dropped 17 points if the
hype for AI and more specifically to
them AI Hardware deflates Jensen might
have to trade his crocodile leather
jacket for a regular leather jacket but
with all of that said without a clear
competitor in the GPU space and video
will still sell a buttload of these to
Gamers and will continue to drive the
industry in the direction of they're
choosing so until AMD or Intel brings
the Heat this is what we got really kind
of feels like the Intel uh hey that's a
nice quad core you got there how about
this shiny new quad core days all I can
do is hope at this point then that
Nvidia can nearly render some more
innovative ideas before they suffer the
same eventual fate that Intel did just
like I'm going to nearly render this
segue to our
sponsor what you expected an AI to come
up with a new segue I mean it was
trained on my segue to our sponsor
Bessie hiding a stash in your shoes is
nothing special keeping it dry while
stepping through water that's what
vessie can offer still Dy now not your
typical clunky robber rain F they kind
of leave your feet looking and smelling
like blue cheese not only they keep your
s dry but also stay breathable
lightweight and stretchy plus they look
way more stylish check out the Ulta high
top it's got a thicker snow gripping
also a warm liner to keep your feet cozy
and comfy whether you are chasing your
New Year's goals or running away from
your responsibilities in the ram vessie
got you covered we have been working
with vasie for years and so many of our
team members actually wear vasy every
single day including myself check out
v.com / LTT and get automatic 15% off
your first order at checkout thanks for
watching guys if you liked this video
check out our 90 review or check out LTT
labs.com for even more info on these new
cards the site is always getting updated